put on your beekeeper suit
and get ready for an epic Heist it's a
heist guys because Netflix's
Kaleidoscope will have you guessing what
the hell is going on no matter what
episode you start with yes this show can
be watched in any order and in this
video I'll be going over the best order
to watch it some of the biggest
unanswered questions and hidden Clues
you might have missed I've left
timestamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering and while you're
at it why not drop a like And subscribe
I may not always cover what you're
watching but when I do it's pretty
awesome it is pretty awesome when I
first found out this show could be
watched in any order I dismissed it
merely as a gimmick but as I started
watching the series I actually kind of
enjoyed it watching it
non-chronologically had me trying to
film the blanks as to what happened and
why characters did the things they did
first I'm gonna lay out the
chronological order which you can see
here I should also note and correct me
if I'm wrong episode white The Heist is
programmed to be the last episode in
every in instance so the chronological
order is how most traditional narratives
are told but I actually encourage you
not to watch it this way that's because
using this order the episode with the
most reveals and biggest emotional
impact would happen in episode 6 instead
of the final episode where it's better
suited hence why Netflix programmed that
last next for those of you who are
curious is the random order I was given
here you can see I started with the
Prison Break episode and ended with the
heist this order was enjoyable but I
would make some changes for an optimal
viewing experience which leads me to
this here's the order I wish I watched
it in starting with yellow six weeks
before the heist simply because it's a
great intro to all our characters and
it's just a fun episode all around this
is the one where our ragtag group
assembles so we get a brief introduction
to all the characters and it even has
its own Diamond Heist segment now
episodes two to four really is a toss-up
between orange green and blue you can
watch those in any order but I like blue
being right at the Midway point of the
season because because that's the point
leading right up to the heist think of
it as a mid-season Cliffhanger we then
go with red to see the morning after the
heist wondering how the hell everything
went wrong then pink six months after
which gives us some more clues and then
Violet 24 years before the heist this
may be contentious for those of you who
have seen the show but the huge
flashback episode here accomplishes two
things one it shows us the moment that
sparked this whole heist in the first
place the death of Leo's wife and his
subsequent arrest but also establishes
the core emotional threat of the show
which is the relationship between Leo
and his daughter Hannah having this
right before the finale adds greater
pull to arguably the most emotional
scene in the entire season where Hannah
reveals to her father what she did with
the money and why she did it but let me
know what orders you guys watched in and
if there's anything intriguing you got
out of it before we get into the heist
itself it's important to understand why
it's happening in the first place as Leo
will later tell his daughter The Heist
was never about the money 24 years ago
in 1998 to con Men by the names of Ray
Vernon and Graham Davies devised a plot
to steal hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of diamonds from a
Christmas Charity Auction Ray had tried
going legitimate but knowing his auto
shop business was in desperate need of
funds and Graham pleading for his help
he takes on this final heist
unfortunately for Rey The Heist goes
terribly wrong with his wife Lily dying
in a fire his best friend choosing not
to save her and Rey getting arrested so
the big volt Heist was never really
about getting away with seven billion
dollars it was to exact revenge on the
man who took everything away from Leo it
was deeply personal Flash Forward 24
years and Rey who now goes by the Alias
Leo Pap has devised the ultimate plan to
get back at Graham Graham has also
changed his identity to that of Roger
Salas and has built a company protecting
people's assets with state-of-the-ark
vaults kind of ironic that a guy who
spent much of his life stealing money
now protects it in episode blue five
days before the heist Leo Maps out the
seven steps needed to break into the
Vault and steal the 7 million worth of
bonds Step One is making their way into
the loading dock of the SLS building SLS
being Salas Logistics Services the
company owned by Roger this entails
having a fake SLS truck one which RJ
creates a copy of and the security
bypass to get in getting the bypass was
accomplished by cloning the radio
frequency transmitters from an actual
SLS truck which was then copied for the
heist steps two and three are getting
from the loading dock to the Vault
itself which unfortunately is manned by
several guards they get by this by using
some rather ingenious methods like
hooking up a bunch of electrical
batteries to the metal door a plant that
sets off poison gas and the tried and
true tranquilizer dart not included in
these steps but worth mentioning are the
security feeds themselves we see Roger
check in on the live feeds which look
completely normal during the heist
that's because a few days prior Leo
broke into his home and set up a
connection which looped a fake live feed
step 4 is all about gaining access to
the Vault hallway which is easily
bypassed with a key card in episode 5
Leo explains that they already have
access to one of these key cards but we
never really figure out how regardless
this merely opens the door to one of the
vault's most elaborate security features
the gate detector a multi-matrix gate
recognition unit which recognizes your
walk and anyone that isn't supposed to
be there will be picked up bypassing
this is step 5 and they come up with a
rather ingenious method of getting past
this by filling the hall with hundreds
of bees it jams the recognition units
feed allowing Leo in a sort of a b
camouflage suit to access the terminal
at the end of the hall and shut it down
they also have the queen bee in this
little container which they'll use to
Corral the bees once they're no longer
of use step 6 is by far the most
difficult to overcome they have to
access the Vault itself and deal with
its temperature sensors accessing The
Vault requires three things something
you are something you have and something
you know only one man has all three of
these things Roger Salas and leading up
to the heist the team found ingenious
ways to get around this first something
you are this refers to Roger's facial
recognition by spiking Roger's contact
lens solution it caused an eye
irritation which Hannah used to call a
fake doctor Stan who used this device to
completely scan his face allowing them
to 3D print a replica this is something
you have refers to this small metallic
ball which Leo has carved a replica of
we know throughout the series this guy
really likes to carve and finally
something you know this is a password
that will disable the temperature
sensors but is only known by Roger and
to make things more difficult it changes
every day originally Leo paid the
manufacture of the Vault fifty thousand
dollars some seven years ago to secretly
install a back door to bypass this but
this was discovered by Roger and is no
longer of use this is where Judy the
hurricane and Kim history come into play
it just so happens that the Vault
conveniently sits atop an abandoned
water tunnel a water tunnel that's right
below the Wall Street subway station
flooding caused by the hurricane would
allow them to set off a bomb allowing
water to flow from the subway station to
the water tunnel setting off a number of
strategically placed cesium charges
cesium when mixed with water creates an
explosion which would allow water to
rain down and disrupt the temperature
sensors it's briefly mentioned in the
series but Judy is the daughter of a
famed chemistry professor so that's
likely where she picked up a lot of her
chemistry know-how the final step is
cracking the safes themselves this was
to be done entirely by Bob an expert
safe cracker but since he got his hand
shot a few weeks prior he'll need the
help of Stan if all goes according to
plan the bonds will be moved onto the
truck which has been changed to be
looked like one run by Con Edison that's
a brilliant move considering Con Edison
is a power company that would absolutely
have trucks out in the wake of a
hurricane where power would be out
unfortunately it's later revealed that
the bonds have been switched and in the
show's biggest reveal it was Hannah who
did it in the final episode white Hannah
reveals to her father that she was the
one to switch the bonds not for the
money but to save all of their lives she
knew the triplets three powerful Bankers
who own these bonds would have them
hunted down and killed should the heist
be successful so in order to save their
lives and that of her unborn child she
proposed a plan to the triplets the day
after the bonds were moved into Roger's
Vault the triplets tasked Roger with
converting them to a quote cleaner asset
you see all these Bonds were created
before 1982 when bonds were not required
to be registered making them untraceable
and ripe for criminal activity with the
triplets facing increased scrutiny by
global governments and monetary
institutions they want to rid themselves
of these potential damaging bonds this
is where Hannah comes in and offers an
ingenious solution let her steal the
bonds the insurance will pay the
triplets back and then the actual bonds
which were FedEx to the Caymans can be
picked up by the triplets under complete
secrecy in essence the triplets are
making an easy 7 billion dollars in
clean money and getting their bonds back
safely tucked away in the Caribbean in
exchange Hannah doesn't have to worry
about her or her father ever being
hunted down now let's talk a bit about
what was in Roger's safe remember that
Leo's motivation for the heist wasn't
really the money rather Revenge he
wanted Roger to pay for what he did and
to know it was him who did it and what
better way than by stashing rapachini's
Orchid the diamond stolen from the
charity auctioned 24 years ago we saw
Leo stash it in this white pouch in the
Violet episode and retrieve it from a
safe in The Heist episode in that same
pouch he kept a hold of it for this very
moment in the pink episode six months
after the heist we see FBI agent nizan
Abbasi collapsed shortly after shaking
hands with a man on the streets of New
York City the show never explicitly
gives us an answer on who was behind
this but considering and was told by her
Superior to stop looking into the heist
yet continued to do so it's highly
likely this was the work of the triplets
there's even a line in the blue episode
where Roger describes what could happen
if you cross the triplets you're walking
down the streets on brushes your arm
three blocks later you dropped out of a
heart attack last but not least we can't
forget our boy Leo we're in the pink
episode it's heavily implied he's killed
the fact he's seen walking with some
luggage perhaps to finally visit his
daughter and Grandson makes it even more
tragic but who shot him well judging by
the shirt worn by the assailant it's
Roger's son Brad who wore the exact same
shirt in the White episode Brad's son
doing this also highlights the Show's
theme of Revenge Brad would want to get
back at the man who put his father in
jail and who also stifled his own plans
to work at his dad's company remember in
the White episode Brad pleaded to his
father to get him a job at SLS rather
than go to college now I really enjoyed
Kaleidoscope I thought it was a lot of
fun but what did you think is this Heist
worth it or is it a pass I want to hear
your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember